we have new information about the search
warrant that led minneapolis police to
the apartment where an officer shot and
killed amir lock last week during a no
knock raid in the middle of the night
locke was not named in the warrant and
was not part of any investigation police
told the judge a no knock raid was
necessary to protect public safety
locke's family went to the state capitol
yesterday to call for changes in the law
our national correspondent jerica duncan
spoke with his parents
we're demanding that a bill is passed
for the no knock warrants
in the name of mirlock a mirlock's
family is seeking justice in the form of
an arrest of the officer who shot and
killed their 22 year old son
and they want to see an end to no knock
warrants it should be abolished because
i'm sitting here speaking about the
death of amir lot
locke's mother karen wells says the
mayor's temporary ban is not enough damn
executing our son we're going to execute
the entire system body cam footage shows
a swat team entering the apartment of
locke's cousin as lock starts to get up
a gun is seen in his hand before an
officer shoots and kills him locke had
no criminal record was never listed on
the search warrant and the gun was
legally owned did he often sleep with a
gun next to him wherever you lay your
head that was not his place of residence
so if he's laying on the couch
he's going to have his firearm foster
calls to him police say they were
looking for evidence in connection with
the homicide investigation involving
locke's 17-year-old cousin makai camden
speed to say that
because a family member
may have been alleged to
have done something wrong does that mean
a mirror should be sentenced to the
death penalty
in the execution of a no not war
i mean when you think about it it is
just
infuriating in the search warrant
released yesterday police argued that
speed social media posts showed various
firearms and that a no knock warrant was
necessary because it was more safe for
officers and would also decrease the
risk for injuries to the suspects and
other residents nearby
the warrant was for property not for a
particular person
so
they did not use a baton
pepper spray mace
um
sun gun taser
all these different methods you chose
the lethal one what do you think your
son is saying right now
he knows how his mother is and he knows
i will not stop
until
everyone involved is brought to justice
so the officer who shot locke is now on
administrative leave cbs news has
reached out to the minneapolis attorney
general the mayor the police department
but they say right now they're not
commenting while the case is still
ongoing police did arrest locke's cousin
again on monday he faces second degree
murder charges
all right thank you very much we'll keep
following it